thanks very much Dennis thanks Dennis
and Andy for inviting me to this and are
very pleased to be here Dennis didn't
mention that i'm actually a Stanford
alum in fact this fall quarter I will be
the 50th anniversary of the time I got
off the bus from Montana and walked up
palm drive with my suitcases I actually
still remember that morning and in the
meantime a fair modest happened
obviously it's a long time ago but I've
been spending a large portion of that
time doing things that are related what
we're going to be talking about today so
it's kind of nice to come back actually
I walk around Stanford one of the things
that impresses me besides the new
buildings is the fact that I can't quite
get out of my mind by looking for my
bicycle i know i left at some place over
near tresidder when I left that that may
or june at the end of the four years but
someplace around here there ought to be
about a 60 year old bicycle maybe rather
beat up but but still hopefully
functional anyway here's what I want to
talk about as Dennis said I'm interested
in long-term global futures and actually
we don't use the word prediction
generally Andy and adenosine my and my
my work because fundamentally I don't
believe we can predict the future what
we can try to do is explore alternative
possibilities and think about what we
might do in order to move it more or
less in the direction of our preferred
alternative futures when I think about
issues around the next over the rest of
the century over the 21st century this
is an oversimplification but I tend to
cluster them into three categories human
development social development of
sustainable development about human
development I mean basically the
reduction of poverty the reduction of
hunger which are very closely related
obviously the advance of education the
advance of
and life expectancy my social
development I'm talking about things
such as the reduction of conflict the
improvement of social relationships
generally the development of governance
capacity both formal and informal the
inclusion of people widely within the
society by by sustainable development
I'm talking about the relationship
between humans and the environment both
in terms of what we put out into the
environment and what we do in terms of
taking from the environment or being
affected by the environment those those
may be an oversimplification but I think
fundamentally most of the issues we're
addressing in the 21st century in terms
of the human the human development
condition human improving the human
condition fall into those categories and
those categories are very much related
just you know a lot of this if not all
of it but just a quick review with
respect to human development stylized
fact roughly a billion people around the
world are living on about a dollar and a
quarter or less a day and those same
billion people are the ones who are
suffering from undernutrition in fact
that's the way we generally defined
under under nutrition and poverty is in
terms of that relationship the fact that
we now have a close to a billion people
who are also obese and that number is
going up is another another cluster of
issues that comes into human development
but it's not the one I'm going to be
focused on now even though the the
system does in fact allow us to begin
looking at those more modern dual burden
kinds of health issues another style I
fact that maybe it's less familiar to
you in places like sub-saharan Africa
and South Asia the average adult still
has less than five years of formal
education my own grandparents had three
and six years my paternal side had three
and six years so we know how rapidly
that can change in a society but right
now that's the pattern in those in those
developing regions with respect to life
expectancy five countries around the
world have life expectancy of less than
than 50 years 35 have life expectancy
less than 60
years and this compares to the kind of
the gold standard out there these days
which is Japan at about 84 in terms of
social challenges just again a quick
refresher the global Gini index that's a
measure of distribution of income or
other phenomena and those of you don't
know about that i'll put a little
context the global Gini index for income
of about point seven is about what South
Africa as a country has right now one of
the most inegalitarian countries in the
world the the global put this an even
more concrete terminology for some of
you the global ratio of incomes from the
ten richest a percent of the global
population of the ten poor percent is
about a hundred to one on average that's
about the same actually i just read
recently between hedge fund managers
last year and bank presidents large bank
presidents but i think that hundred to
one in that particular set of categories
doesn't matter quite as much as this
hundred to one matters in terms of a
formal democracy that is to say
competitive elections about 107
countries already around the world are
democratic but 24-hour very
authoritarian and the rest of the
countries around the world or someplace
in between in terms of inclusion going
further on this the gender empowerment
measure developed by the united nations
human development report puts one at
equality the countries that come closest
to that are in scandinavia for the most
part and they run about point nine about
half of the world's countries are point
five and below so there are lots of
dimensions of any conclusion including
gender empowerment but minority
inclusion where things are extremely
underdeveloped at this point turning to
the third set of challenges around
sustainable development globally we
admit right now about 8.5 gigatonnes of
carbon dioxide from our fossil fuel use
every year it's climbing by 2 12 2020
already will be x 9.5 that's billion
tons of carbon dioxide
those numbers are hard for me to get my
mind around sometimes but in terms of
the fossil fuels we use to to to admit
that much right now it's about 3200
billion gallons of gasoline equivalent
that's about three point two trillion
dollar trillion gallons of gasoline
around the year in terms of fossil fuel
use converting all fossil fuels into the
same energy content 450 gallons per
person in the u.s. more than 2,000
gallons actually I was surprised that
that number in u.s. wasn't higher I've
sometimes been in line at a self-service
station behind a Hummer and I thought
they were going to put in about that
much themselves but but that's where we
are as a country right now now studying
these three problems these three sets of
problems and I would argue very strongly
that if you want to study these problems
you really ought to study the Minotaur
interaction because I don't think you
can get human development without Social
Development I don't think you can have
sustainable development without human
development and social development I
think these things go together it's hard
to know where to cut into the cluster of
problems I personally actually have a
bit of a bias towards human development
because it's something we can focus on
education health reduction of poverty
but all three of these things are things
that require our attention so how do in
terms of a computer tool for again not
predicting but for helping us think
about them and explore them what would
that tool look like the weed obviously
have to have a representation of
demography and let me talk just about
this a bit here at Stanford and my own
University our University of Denver we
increasingly are breaking down the stove
pipes or the silos of our disciplines
and looking across but in a modeling
world there's still an awful lot of
siloing if you look at the people who
are studying in forecasting in the
demographic area let's take the United
Nations Population division or the US
census bureau the the larger models of
population and
presenting age and sex cohorts and
representing changes and fertility and
mortality patterns those models tend to
be largely isolated from other kinds of
forecasting representations and that
obviously in my mind is not something we
should be doing we should be linking
those models we should be endogenous
many of the variables as we possibly can
another kind of representation we need
is an economic representation economic
model economists whether it's at the
World Bank or at the OECD Organisation
for Economic Cooperation and Development
tend to model the economy ins more or
less the same sort of way an equilibrium
process between a supply-side and demand
side and the interaction of those that
dynamic unfolding over time again most
of those economic models tend to be
pretty much isolated from other kinds of
representations even from the
demographic which is to say that even
the labor force forecasts from
population models are often taken
offline and and become X exogenous
inputs to the economic model much less
the economic model feeding back and
affecting the the demographic model
those are two models that we have taken
and and put it into the International
future system and in and basically
connected to each other you what if you
turn to again in the human development
area turn to education there are many
models that forecast education out there
about the only one that I'm really aware
of besides the one we've developed and
i'll be showing you here and short time
is is at the International Institute for
applied systems analysis and outside of
Vienna Locsin burg and they have a model
of Education formal education
representing a primary secondary
tertiary education and in we've we've
constructed fundamentally the same kind
of system if the health in health area
the World Health Organization has done
some forecasting in a project called the
global burden of disease in some model
development again largely isolated from
the other kinds of representations we
have taken the kind of representation
they have done
and built it into a system that has
these other components as well I'm going
to come back to infrastructure on the
social development side we've done
representations of domestic governance
development and also international
political development so we've got the
human we've got here the human
development kinds of activities we've
got the social development activities
and over here we have some of the
relationships to the environment the
sustainable development activities
you're going to talk about sustainable
human development you have to talk about
our agriculture in our energy system
because those are two places where we
interact most aggressively so to speak
with our natural environment putting out
things taking things from that
environment you have to have some
representation of environmental resource
and quality variables such as carbon
dioxide and greenhouse effect or water
use you have to have some representation
obviously a technological development
some of the earlier integrated models
were often of justly criticized for not
having some effort to endogenous and
represent technology as well and the
most important thing from my point of
view is you need to put all of these
these elements together and that's what
we've been trying to do for much of the
period since I lost my bicycle around
here okay the international futures
project it's hosted at the Frederick s
Pardee Center at the University of
Denver Josef Korbel School I've been
working on this and others have been
working on this maybe less time but over
thirty plus year period we're focused on
long-term integrated scenario analysis
that's alternative futures we have done
projects for a wide variety of
organizations we contributed to
something called the global
environmental outlook of the united
nations environment program we
contributed now to the last two of the
human development reports of the UN
Development Program in fact the human
development report used to be largely a
discussion of where we are globally and
then last two we have introduced
forecasting particularly this last one
that just came out we've worked with the
European Commission on projects we've
worked with an
national intelligence council that's an
organization that every four years
prepares a report on global trends of
the President and we've supported last
three of those and we've got a volume
series that I'm advertising at the
bottom but is freely available online I
here is kind of my vision for where we
should be going and in it in terms of
development of a system to look at these
problems and to try to analyze what's
going on in these systems interacting
systems long-term we need strong data
foundations we need systems that can
import as automatically as possible
large numbers of data series we need
formulations in the model we need to be
continually enhancing those and most
importantly perhaps in many ways is we
need to make those systems as
transparent and open as possible we need
the system to be user friendly with an
interactive interface for building
scenarios for building alternative
futures we need to be an open and free
system what I'm going to show you has
quite a bit of those four elements
already we need a couple of other
elements and these there's the places I
want to go as we go forward and in this
whole enterprise we need to
institutionalize these things so that
the systems that we're developing our
online actually actually as if she is
but open which is to say we need to be
able to drop in new modules for
representative fertility or the
production function or the availability
of resources in the constraints it
places upon our economic development or
doesn't place upon it and we need a
variety of strategy search tools to be
able to go through these systems and
look for paths towards the more
desirable futures so this is what we're
trying to do and not be showing you now
basically how how we can do these things
or to the extent that we can do these
things now and where we might be going
now the access to this international
future system and by the way the acronym
ifs with a small s if-then statements
it's it's all about if this then that
and futures are conditional and are
conditional in many respects on on human
choice
you can freely download that or actually
use an online version I'm going to be
showing you the downline version the
online version has a bit snazzier
graphics and nice features in many
respects but I don't fully trust
interaction with the web for a
demonstration and and I saw you i'm
going to use the down downloaded version
and you can get either there we have
taken a number of our forecast quite a
few of our forecasts and we put them
into a online database called global
public data Explorer the global the
zooming google public data Explorer
google has about the technology of
Gapminder anybody remember the ted the
famous TEDx talk that hans Rosling gave
you seen have you seen that hans Rosling
did a wonderful set of presentations on
human development basic clay and his
system for doing that is called
Gapminder and it allows the people to to
see what's going on there actually as
long as as long as I'm talking about
that oops didn't mean to do that long as
I'm talking about that let's let's
switch over and let's actually go to
that I'll show you the kind of thing
that that that Hans Rosling did with
historical data and we can do with our
hit with our forecast what about the
alternative forecasts here are two
variables life expectancy in years and
why I didn't pull out a pointer I have
no idea
now we'll forget about the point our
life expectancy in years and each one of
these each one of these points is a
country they're scaled by population and
then we have over here total fertility
which is the number of births that each
woman on average in a society has per
year so this gives you a pretty good
idea of human development and if you
look up here at the top and left if you
look up at this point right here baby
this won't surprise you that this is
Afghanistan basically a life expectancy
of forty five point five years in 2010
and a fertility rate which is a bit more
than six children per woman it probably
also won't surprise you that if we look
over here we've got Somalia if you look
over here we have Molly recently in the
news and over here we have Zambia down
here we have Chad another African
country that has a low level of
development on both of these indicators
down here we have night Nigeria and up
here we have the congo the democratic
republic of the congo a lot of our of
our difficult development cases of human
development cases sit up and up in this
quadrant right here India and China and
I know it's there used to sit up in that
quadrant not very many years ago if you
go back about 30 40 years some of these
countries that are down here many of
these countries that are down here we're
up here now on the on the path that we
are currently on in what we often refer
to as the base case of the International
future system that is to say we just
kind of let the world evolve as it has
been these are not individual
projections this is not taking life
expectancy and just extrapolating it or
taking fertility rate and just
extrapolating this now this is the
interaction of all those pieces of the
model that I was showing you so the
fertility rate is being affected by
income by education of women by the use
of contraception life expectancy is a
function of all kinds of different
variables the whole health module but on
the path that we seem to be on
yeah if we take a look at where this is
going it it doesn't take too many years
even a little bit beyond 2020 that we
have seen quite a movement down towards
higher levels of human development and
if we continue this going forward we can
see in fact a story a very interesting
story not the only story of the future I
know Dennis and I had lunch together and
and we and he's much more pessimistic
about some of this than I am perhaps but
on the human development story has been
in over the last 40 or 50 years an
incredible positive one we have made
remarkable advances and that's the kind
of trajectory we are on and doesn't mean
that the trajectory can't be shifted by
bad governance or by by major
environmental problems but it does mean
that that's that's the path right now
question Eddie couldn't all of the
bubbles on the line or below the line to
be getting smaller as the private dances
all the bubbles below to below to
shouldn't beginning smaller no
necessarily in population forecasting
you have a phenomena that's called
momentum if you have a population
distribution and we'll actually i'll
show you one of these in just a couple
minutes elaborate on this this answer
but if you have a population
distribution this kind of pyramid shaped
even if the people in their 20s and 30s
are only having two children you're
still getting a lot more children at the
bottom then you have people die at the
top I'll explain that in just a minute
so you can still have population growth
for for about 20 or 30 years after you
begin to reach what is called
equilibrium fertility around 2.1 you
presumably better that is because the
age at which you die increases that's
that's part of it also that's that
that's a very much related or
supplemental factor in terms of
continuing to keep those those bubbles
fairly large ok this is I want to stress
this is these are packaged forecasts
that we've given to the Google Data
public data Explorer I want to show you
the live stuff
to show you the stuff coming out of the
model so I'm going to jump out of this
and go back what I'm going to do
actually well I'll tell you one more
thing that's kind of interesting I think
before I before I go in in there I'm
going to come down back down into here
and start here and just jump quickly to
Wikipedia
I'm kind of showing something here that
I i I'm very pleased about and that's
the widespread availability of our
forecasts if you go to almost any
country under Wikipedia you go to Brazil
you go to Congo you go to India China
whatever and you scroll down near the
bottom on Wikipedia pages there tends to
be a a something called external links
and in the external links you'll see
forecasts for Brazil from international
futures that's us and if you go to that
linkage with a little luck that will
take us directly into international
futures model try it again okay it's now
right down here oops do the other tab
okay let's try it again where do you see
it pop good more ah there we go okay we
are now looking at international futures
forecast we're actually in the model
we're looking at for Brazil and you
could see up here we've got categories
of forecasts population health education
all the elements that was telling you
about and if somebody or any place
obviously and we hope students in even
in high schools or elsewhere we'll pick
this up if they're interested in a
forecast for brazil's population they
can go in here and pull this up and what
will be showing them on the web is the
history historical pattern of population
growth from our historical database up
until 2010 and then our forecast going
forward and this then allows them to get
into the international future system and
jump around and look at pretty much
anything else they want to so this is
the web-based version that we're not
going to be focused on but I wanted you
to know how relatively easy it is to get
in there
so now we're going to turn to the actual
model and we'll open that up and this is
the this is the downloadable version and
I want to talk a little bit about this
look at the menu at the top you've got
three major functionalities you've got
data analysis we've pulled about 2500
data series from all the major
international organizations and a lot of
think tanks and research groups around
the world for 183 actually now 186
countries around the world from 1960
forward it's hard to get a lot of social
economic data prior to nineteen
sixty-four most of the African countries
weren't even independent we pull that
data into a database we can show it on
GIS map kind of form we can also do what
are called longitudinal analyses looking
at a series and extrapolating or we can
do cost sectional analyses looking at
relationship between one variable or
another and we'll come back and we'll do
some of this that's one functionality
another functionality is display all the
major display forms line graphs bar
charts group tables pie charts you can
take from our base case that when I was
talking about before letting the system
kind of rip or you can take it from one
of the scenarios we've developed and do
a comparative analysis between the
alternative world future and the end of
base case the third kind of thing we can
do in this system is then develop a new
scenario we want access to all the
parameters or initial conditions in the
model we want to be able to change them
fairly flexibly rerun the model and and
and create evolve alternative images of
the world those are the three things
that we want to be able to do there's
some extended features help system and
so on but we don't need to go there
right now now before before I begin to
show you some of these these features in
these categories let me just ask you is
there a particular country that you're
interested in of anything other than
North Korea North Korea's got pretty
lousy data give me a country to look at
skol scotland ah scottish nationalists
but would be fine okay how about we come
back we've written since it's actually a
country right now okay sorta okay we'll
zoom in here and we'll pick up Great
Britain and we'll look at for instance
we'll start with the population by agent
sex because we were just talking about
that this is the population distribution
five-year categories and we have here
males and females represented on the
same side of this many of you are used
to seeing a distribution of this that
people refer to often as the population
pyramid used to seeing it like this so
that you can see the males and females
left and right the reason we pretend to
present it like this is because if you
look at certain countries let's change
this over for instance to China you look
at China you can see down here the male
selection bias with children very
clearly this is selective abortion or
maybe even to some degree infanticide
but it's it's very definitely a larger
number of males much more than you would
get in a natural birth situation and and
obviously this is going to have a social
effect let me pick a different different
country than either one of these let me
go to something like let's go to
something like well first of all me show
you Japan here we have in 2010 on age
sex distribution which is going to be
problematic what you see is so few young
people that as we advance this overtime
2015 2020 this is our base case forecast
I'm showing you your rapidly approaching
a situation where you're going to have a
huge number of retirements and a very
small population base in the working
years to support them this is a social
issue that we we know pretty well about
I'm going to go back here because I want
to pick up Andy's question again I'm
going to go back to a country
like Nigeria which has a much bigger
base down here and Andy here's a
situation if Nigerians tomorrow started
having an average of two children or 2.1
children per couple you'd have a
situation where these young people here
are having so many children compared to
the number who are likely to be dying at
the top that that this this pyramid
mates may flatten so to speak it may
drop and become relatively square at the
bottom but it's still going to be an
increasing population plus the
increasing life expectancy that you were
talking about so you know these these
factors all influence the demographic
patterns let's stay with let's say with
Nigeria for a moment because I there are
some things that I think are more
interesting perhaps than the United
Kingdom that I wanted to show you let's
let's zoom in on Nigeria over here
instead and instead of looking at
population let's look at the education
pattern this is the same kind of pyramid
you're used to seeing but what we're
looking at now is that population
pyramid broken down into the levels of
education the red here is the number is
people at different age and sex levels
that have not completed a primary
education the people the average in
Africa is less than than six years of
education is less than five actually so
you've got a lot of people who've never
completed primary education the green is
primary only the yellow is secondary but
not higher and the blue this blue
slippers here are tertiary
and obviously this pattern is changing
again if we forecast it we're going to
see a growth in the tertiary going to
see growth in a secondary shrinkage in
the in the non primary but but this is a
very different pattern obviously than we
would see if we looked at let's say and
switch over and take a look at the
United States very different age sex
pattern very different education pattern
let's switch over and take a quick look
at pakistan and here we that's not
pakistan it looked like Palestine to me
and thick that's Panama we'll get it
here Pakistan and Pakistan we see we see
a very large bulge of women who have not
received even a primary education
relative to the male's a very great
gender disparity here so this is one use
of the model this is a use of the model
where you're just exploring to see what
seems to be happening in the base case
and we can do this country by country or
we can do it regionally but I want to
take us in slightly different places
let's go let's go back and let's try to
look at some of the stories that the
model might be telling us about human
development social development
sustainable development and where the
issues are where the possible problems
and some of the intervention points
might be let's start with human
development I'm going to go in the data
analysis and I'm going to I'm going to
take us to cross sectional analysis and
I want to look at first of all since
we've been talking about education i'm
going to oh i should say these are the
two thousand five hundred or so
variables at cause agriculture education
energy etc that we've gathered data on
they're all available for for you as a
user the model to use you can also
export some of these things but i'm
going to just pick one of them education
years i'm going to pick the average
years of education that adults 15 and
above have i can by the way look at the
data information and find out where this
this this data came from we try to
obviously give attribution
when we pulled data into the system but
I'm going to select that for the most
recent year for which we have data then
I'm going to look at GDP in two thousand
five dollars per capita that's something
called purchasing power parody not
everybody here is going to be familiar
with purchasing power parity but that
tries to look at the size of an economy
based upon a production or consumption
of a market basket of goods as opposed
to the official exchange rates between
countries it's a better way of getting
at how well to do a country really is
going to pick that as the independent
variable the first independent variable
plot this and we'll see that this is GDP
per capita $10,000 up to eighty thousand
dollars these are the education years
from two years of education less than
two years for Molly up to twelve
thirteen years for countries like the
United States in Norway for the average
adult I'm going to just quickly fit a
logarithmic curve to this which is not
the I not perfect but it gives us a
reasonably good fit to start with and we
can see the kind of pattern that often
happens is we look at human development
variables in relationship to income and
income advanced one of the stories that
with respect to human development that's
very important global you is what I
often refer to as the sweet spot of
development if you look at this between
zero and ten thousand dollars per capita
is where most of the rise occurs in
education by the time you get up to
about ten thousand dollars per capita
you're beginning to get to a fairly low
level of increase in education year by
year and that is not just true of
education that's going to be true a
fertility reduction is going to be true
in life expectancy advanced it's two of
a whole lot of variables around human
development and it's one of the reasons
for a certain degree of optimism because
these countries down here tend to have
fairly decent growth rates over the last
decade 15-20 years and if we stay on
track there's a lot of potential for
moving a lot of them up into higher
level of development
now countries perform very differently
let's let's take a look at that
different differential performance let
me turn off the labels for most of these
countries and just focus on a couple let
me focus on let's pick up for instance
if anybody has a country you're
particularly interested in you can you
can tell me but I'm going to pick and
let's let's pick Reese and let's pick an
electrophile myself i'm going to pick
turkey blondes that pic turkey let's
pick Reese let's pick the arch rival
Turkey come on down here and let's take
a look at them and you can see because I
didn't get turkey did I back and do that
again found it but not clicked on it
okay so here's grease up here and here's
turkey down here now this we often look
at countries in terms of human
development in terms of benchmarking
them how are they doing relative to the
typical global pattern a grease looks to
be doing about as well or somewhat
better than the average pattern based
upon this this line fit turkey is not
doing so well Turkey has advancement to
be made in terms of Education
considerable advancement they're running
behind their peers given their general
income level I'll take a different
variable let's go over here and pick for
instance sanitation I want to pick
sanitation access the percentage of the
population that has access to to improve
sanitation and as I said before we're
going to find a somewhat similar
relationship in terms of the sweet spot
here by the time countries get up to
about ten thousand dollars per capita
someplace in the neighborhood of 80 and
even ninety percent of their populations
tend to have improved sanitation access
but what we're seeing here again is that
there are a lot of countries that are
very far away from that pattern by zoom
in here for instance Equatorial Guinea
Botswana algebra John these are
countries that fall considerably below
the the the curve and there are
countries that we would focus on is
potential problem countries in terms of
human development many of you here
familiar with the Millennium Development
Goals lenham Development Goals used
1990s a base year and said that by 2015
which is only two years from now most
all countries should make huge advances
in these these human development
variables Equatorial Guinea is not going
to do it they're not going to make those
advances Azerbaijan down here is not
going to do it the Republic of Congo is
not going to do it we have to take into
account as we go forward in the
next generation of global goals we have
to take into account initial starting
positions and where countries might go
over the next 15 or 20 years one of the
things we're trying to do in our project
right now we're trying to work with for
instance African Union institutions that
will help set the next generation of
goals for many of the African countries
let's let's turn to a different kind of
variable let's turn to to something that
we call performance risk evaluation
we're going to move to the social side
as opposed to thee to the human
development side we were looking at
nigeria lasso Nigeria popped up for us
before many of you familiar with the
concept of the the press talks about all
the time of state failure they'd failure
of the countries that are having real
trouble I'm going to take you a question
in just just a minute I'm not ignoring
it then just going to finish this
thought every every year foreign policy
magazine puts out something on state
failure there are all kinds of other
indices of state failure state failure
in my mind is it too blunt a concept
what we've tried to do here is we've
tried to look at different aspects of
state performance whether it's around
security capacity inclusion
environmental variables are economic
variables health and so on and give
countries a performance evaluation based
upon how they're doing kind of like that
benchmarking exercise I was just talking
about now if we look at all the
countries in the world we're going to
find that Nigeria fits 12 and though in
the in the countries that you would
expect to be among the worst performance
performance Democratic Republic of the
Congo Sudan Somalia Chad Afghanistan are
right here near the top but what we're
trying to do is we're trying to figure
out on what things they do what things
they do well what things they do poorly
and and you have countries that are
doing poorly on on
poverty reduction you have countries
that are doing poorly on environmental
variables you have countries that are
doing poorly in terms of dealing with
inclusion and minority problems conflict
internally we're going to we're breaking
down this performance in two different
dimensions in order to analyze Social
Development much more completely
question in the back oh but it's Martin
show this really that some countries are
behind their peers in I'm sorry my
hearing is not really good let's try
this again oh well this is graphs show
that some countries are behind their
peers in terms of some development
indices does it offer any insight on why
those countries and why the why those
countries are behind that is exactly of
course what we want to analyze with this
system and what we're going to be doing
when we do that kind of analysis is
we'll pick a variable let's let's go
down into a different section of the
model and answer to your question
question again was why do some countries
not do as well as other countries on
some of these variables if we go into
the display section of the model and go
into what we call self-managed display
all the variables and all the parameters
of the model are here so let's take that
one we were looking at which is called
ed education years and i'll pick that
variable and i'll just pick it for
afghanistan which wasn't doing so well
with old population i'll bring it down
here and then i'll ask the model to tell
me a little bit about what's going on in
the education area i'll ask it for
instance to give me the drivers that is
to say and let's go up here and let's
show the definitions so we have this
education years age 15 this is the
variable we were looking at and these
are the variables in the model that go
into the calculation of that and these
are the variables that that that are
influenced by that and if we wanted this
this for instance is the secondary the
upper secondary graduation rate and if
we wanted to look at that
the dependent variable we can click here
and find the kinds of things that drive
that so this begins to help us
understand what's going on inside the
model now there are some other ways we
can also try to track this down for
instance inside the help system website
I want to go there I want to go back I
want to go back here to the main help
system of the model and we have
something we here we call understanding
the model opening the black box I
emphasized earlier that a model like
this has got to try to create
transparency and it's a very difficult
thing to do because if you don't but if
you don't have transparency you can't
trace what's going on or what's driving
good performance or bad performance so
in if we go into into the opening the
black box we can see here let me pick an
area the model like the demographic area
open that up and we can see various flow
charts or block diagrams for instance
around fertility this describes how the
model works and what the variables are
the connect around the the fertility
area of the model if we want to come
down further here we can open up the
equations of the model and again if we
pick fertility we can see the actual for
equations inside the model that
explained the fertility rate now if
you're really and many people in this
audience are obviously going to be
interested in this sort of thing come
down to the model code open that up and
inside the model code you will actually
see some of the code that's determining
what's going on here now i have to tell
you we do not keep this help system as
up-to-date as we would like to we're
always behind the curb we're always
developing the model faster than we can
keep the documentation up to speed but
it is one of the major pushes were
making right now in this project is to
try to enhance our documentation and
these mechanisms that I've just shown
you for trying to open the black box
looking at the driver map going into the
help system look at the equations those
are the ones that were that were working
on now I'd love to be able to to do this
in a more systematic way and and some of
you in this audience might have have
ideas as to how to do that for instance
the the drivers map that I showed you
the independent variables and the
dependent variables with respect to any
any anything in the model that's done by
parsing the code and searching for the
equations well but many of you obviously
know that probably everybody here knows
that a model like this is not just a set
of equations it's also a set of
algorithms and there are going to be a
large number of rule-based kind of
determinations that are difficult to
represent in terms of equations and
difficult to parse least it's been
difficult for us to parts some of you
might be able to figure out procedures
that do that much more systematically if
I answered your question to some degree
at least I guess okay let's let's
continue here we were looking at
performance risk let's continue to work
in the area of social change for a
moment social development and I'm going
to take you into this thing that's
called flexible display actually get
back in the main menu again we had the
data analysis we've looked at that to
some degree just scratch the surface of
it obviously we'd looked at some cost
sectional analyses and that's all we've
done selectively we've got we've started
looking at some of the display features
and we haven't even gotten a scenario
analysis yet but I'm going to take you
into display features I'm going to take
you into something we call flexible
display and this flexible display has
all the major categories of the model
again over here on the left and if I
pick a category let's pick governance of
in the social area I see variables for
governance and i'm going to pick the
security variable the governance index
for security that we've created we are
or trying to represent governance in
terms of three major categories security
capacity and inclusion you have
historically the year
in countries and back in the 1800's were
focused or 1700 1800 are focused on
developing security control over their
territory prevention of of invasion of
their territory it was only later they
began to develop capacity for extracting
revenues and and building infrastructure
and so on it was still later that they
began to develop inclusion Democratic
forms so there were three transitions
and governance that went on these days
developing countries in Africa and Asia
are being asked to do all three of those
transitions together and they're
succeeding or failing in very different
ways I'm going to pick the security one
to begin with and we'll take two of the
most important countries in the world
today we'll take China and we'll take
India monsters of the other of the
demographic environment and soon-to-be
of the economic environment and we'll
focus on a base case and let's just take
a look at what they're doing here in
terms of security on an index that runs
roughly from 0 to 1 china now is up in
the point 65 range which means they've
established really quite secure systems
internally and obviously in places like
to bet there's still a great and Orson
Jong there's there's a great deal of
conflict heavily suppressed often but it
is fundamentally stable a situation more
or less India on the other hand in ERISA
at the knox elite's some of the the
northeast territories has a great deal
of instability so they're actually lower
on the security dimension in general
again historically and Dennis I'm going
to come back to you because of our
discussion over lunch even if we're
somewhat pessimistic about where we're
going now well if you go back over the
last 20 or 30 years these trends these
these things have been coming up in
interaction with the human development
side of things that I was showing you
and if patterns continue to unfold more
or less as they have been historically
everything interacting we would expect a
continued progress on these dimensions
now let me switch over and let's pick
the the capacity index and do the same
sort of thing and on the capacity index
which is the ability to mobilize
revenues and also to use them quite
effectively without dramatic levels of
corruption I neither one of these
countries is that I and the index they
both have high levels of corruption but
but China again is above where India is
and both are on an upward swing for the
most part if we look at the inclusion
dimension the pattern is very different
from the other two here India obviously
has much higher levels of inclusion
China with a not fundamentally
non-democratic system at this point has
much lower levels we would expect this
to continue to rise this is not a
prediction I want to emphasize that no
way do I believe that China will have a
kind of monotonic steady increase in
inclusion it won't happen societies
don't move that that way there will be
fits and starts in reverses this may be
the underlying pattern over the long
term which is about all we can do in a
model like this but it won't happen
exactly like this no where near this is
one very enemy in a way very low
probability future any future I put it
out in front of you here is in many
respects a very low probability future
now let's change from from the social
side of things let's change to the
environmental side let's go over here
i'll pick environment and i'm going to
pick what's what's happening in carbon
emissions and i'm going to pick the
different kind of geography
representation which i'm going to switch
from countries to groups come down here
we've got so many groupings that the
different international organizations
and research institutions use but i'll
pick the non-oecd and the OECD countries
OECD again is the Organization for
Economic Cooperation development it's
the richer countries for the most part
around the world and we'll look at the
way the the carbon emissions are
unfolding this is a pattern it might
surprise you a little bit because the
OECD country
vs the rich countries of the world are
now substantially already below that of
the of the non-oecd countries in terms
of annual carbon emissions gigatonnes or
billion tons of carbon dioxide China in
just the last few years has passed the
u.s. in terms of its emissions the
developing countries on the whole have
passed the developed countries quite a
number of years back the the richer
countries because of improved energy
efficiency relatively low economic
growth and also because of
decarbonisation the movement from coal
to natural gas have been stabilizing and
are on the edge perhaps a beginning to
bring that that handle emissions down
the non-oecd countries are not and the
gap is going to continue to grow when we
deal with the global issues around a
greenhouse gas regime that is to say a
global system to try to bring down the
emissions we are increasingly dealing
with a problem that's in the developing
world now what where is that taking us
here is a I'm going to switch over to
the percentage of the atmosphere the
portion of the atmosphere in parts per
million that are that are carbon dioxide
i'm going to pick four scenarios that we
developed for the for the UN
environmental program and show you the
results of those i'm going to actually
take this all the way out to 2100 now
these are for alternative scenarios
here's roughly where we are now
approaching 400 parts per million carbon
dioxide there isn't a single scenario
here including one it was incredibly
aggressive in terms of its assumptions
for controlling carbon dioxide that
keeps it to 450 parts per million which
many in the end the carbon world are
calling for most of the scenarios go to
500 550 or closer to 600 and actually
none we don't have
a highly pessimistic scenario in here we
could build them with positive feedback
from methane release and other kinds of
forces we could build a much more
pessimistic scenario about where
greenhouse gases are taking us but I
said before that the human development
story is generally positive the social
development story has been generally
positive the onion the environment the
sustainability development story isn't
so positive if you look at water use if
you look at other kinds of environmental
indicators you have much more
conservative concern here appropriately
my difficulty mentally is that I don't
think we're going to get these problems
under control as well as long as we have
a billion people in poverty and hunger
and I don't see how we're going to get
these under control if we don't have
governance social systems with high
levels of capacity in terms of revenue
raising lower corruption and so on all
of these things are interrelated and
we're not going to we've got some major
problems here but it's going to be very
difficult to address them without
addressing the entire complex of things
now one last thing is I see I'm taking
way too long before questions I didn't
mean to go so long i'm sorry but one
more thing i'm going to take you quickly
to the scenario analysis we go into the
scenario analysis with tree and again
every single parameter and every single
initial condition can be changed I'm
going to just show you something we're
working on right now I'm going to go
into some scenario scenario sets here
that we have prepackaged these are
alternative futures each one of these is
alternative future or set of futures
we've been looking at scenarios around
around the energy resources and we've
been looking at what's going to happen
if we continue to expand our
exploitation of shale gas and shale oil
so we've developed to she'll scenario so
a fairly high one for the US and canada
and a very high 14 around the world
where Russia Australia and others are
also developing shale we have run those
scenarios and I'm not going to do it
here we could load
I'll load one of the tree just to show
you what it's like I load this high
shale scenario into the tree and it
makes a lot of changes in assumptions
around our parameters I can then run
this model create a new set of
assumptions and if I do that and go back
to display flexible package display open
that up again I will see down here a
high shale scenario and a shale
resources scenario that i have run and
thus i can compare them to the base in
the same way that it showed you the four
scenarios from unep and i'm not going to
I'm not going to take time to do it
right now but if we did that let me ask
you a question is is is a high shale gas
and oil future greenhouse for green is
it is it friendly to the environment of
less carbon emissions we're hearing a
lot about this these energy forms
replacing coal shutting down coal plants
etc is it a green future or is it
potentially not a green future is it one
that in fact might lead to higher
greenhouse emissions I'm as a professor
I always force everybody in my audience
is always to take a vote I'm going to
I'm going to force it here how many of
you think that the high shelf futures
are going to be green please raise your
hand a couple how many people think it's
going to be potentially not so green
most of you that's what we're seeing in
our initial runs of this analysis we're
seeing that you put more shale gas and
oil into the system you lower energy
prices in the process the person in the
Hummer and with the Humber and a line in
front of me retires it in more years
rather than fewer years or baby buys
something also it's a gas-guzzling we
actually undercut the efforts around the
world to develop renewable energy forms
and to replace coal and other fossil
fuels with those and we're ending up
with a less green future now this is
preliminary in terms of our analysis I'm
done
I'm not going to take this any further I
could show you a little bit of this but
it's time for me to quit it's time for
me to open this up to more discussion so
let me let me do that please how did you
convince yourself that the algorithms
and equations you came up with our valid
or correct or where'd you want it to use
the question is how did I convince
myself or how do I convince myself that
the equations algorithms formulations in
the model are valid correct I can't
fundamentally it's one of the things
that does keep me awake at night is in
fact just this exercise I was just
telling you about five years ago we did
not have shale oil and gas in there
because five years ago we you know began
to get some Inklings that this was a new
development but but we had no idea how
rapidly it was going to happen and our
equations of formulations were wrong
there were changing the month by month
week by week and we're making a big push
to try to keep up with this when I'm
change it but the formulations in the
model that i'm showing you are going to
be wrong now that is that that said what
do we do to make them as right as we can
or is nearly right as we can several
things we're always looking at the
scientific literature in the fields that
we're dealing in so we study other
demographic economic energy models and
we try to extract from them the state of
the art as much as possible in terms of
the way these are represented we're
constantly updating our data and we're
doing our own estimations and analyses
around functions when we run when we put
these in the model and we run them the
first time or two we put new
formulations in it's always obvious
garbage so there's fixing there's we
visiting of everything there's also a
process that people refer to as
historical validation which is to say we
start the model in 1960 since we've got
data in 1960 going back then we run the
model forward and we say how well did we
do and when we do that by the way when
we started 1960 we don't correct things
every year we started 1916 we let it run
for 50 years and say over the entire 50
years how did we do that's not really
historical validation that's that's a
misnomer that's a historical analysis
that's a historical kind of testing
process but even if we got it completely
right for the last 50 years that doesn't
mean we get it right for the next 50 but
it but it's a step in there in the
direction we haven't done as much of
that as we would like because we've been
doing we've been doing other things to
push the model forward but we have done
over over many years a fair amount of
that historical analysis there I'm sure
there are other things that I'm not
thinking about right now but this is a
critical issue you're you've nailed it
yeah tasty deal quality data issue this
point for countries that may be polish
data that's not you know representative
right that is that has some self
interest in its presentation yes the
question is around the the accuracy of
data the possible misrepresentation even
of some of the data almost all of our
data come from international sources we
are not data makers where data takers
and I often reproduces data vacuum
cleaners because we're all we see a new
series out there we tend to grab it and
pull it in the we we do make some data
in the international politics area we're
actually working in some series in in
the center my associate director
Jonathan Moyers leading some projects to
make data around international
governmental organizations treaties and
so on but for the most part where data
takers and in that process we rely on
the evaluation of the World Bank the IMF
the UN fao and they do some cleaning but
they don't do a lot I don't know how
what else to do quite frankly we have a
project right now as I mentioned we had
some projects with Africa and we just
had two weeks ago a couple of our team
members including the head of a of a
strategic part and we have an Africa
think tank called the Institute for
security studies knock you silly are
director he and my social director were
in Pattaya and they convened what they
call a data validation workshop we
brought they brought in a variety of
academic and institutional experts on
different categories of the model
agriculture energy infrastructure and so
on and they sat down showed them what we
had and asked where is this right and
worse is wrong now we were told for
instance of some of our health data
we're pretty bad so we're going to be
hopefully getting some new health data
out of that out of it exercise but we
can't do this for all of the areas of
the model in all the parts of the world
we just don't have the resources so we
we have we know some some pretty weak
data in some areas I don't know I don't
know quite how to address that follow on
oh well this is the flag data that seems
very at odds with other data for may be
the same countries India set as
suspicious ah that's it this is an
interesting question too and this
relates maybe to some of the interests
that some of you have around simulations
a number of years ago I was involved in
a project in actually it was for an
organization in US Naval Intelligence
and it was an earlier simulation that I
helped work on in the 1980s and that's
in that simulation we had a lot of the
same kinds of things and they said your
data are out of date and they paid us
they made it's a contract to update the
data it took us a year and a half two
years to update the data we got all the
data updated we did consistency checks
between one source and another source
another issue is sometimes you have data
in physical forms like barrels of oil
and sometimes you have it in and
monetary terms billions of dollars and
and on the same thing and they don't
they don't match so we took two years to
do this and we got done and presented
and they said that's great but you're
out of date and I went back to the hotel
that night but their colleague of mine
and I said you know I'm not going to
spend my entire life updating data for
this model and trying to reconcile
things so we
developed something we call them
and actually it's in this area that's
called extended features it's called
rebuild a model base this massive
database we have out there which has all
these different data from different
sources and sometimes the same variable
from multiple sources energy production
or the different units and so on the
preprocessor is a collection of
algorithms that did what we did over
those two years and it goes through and
tries to reconcile data clean data it
gives priority to certain sources over
other sources it fills holds the huge
number of countries for which we have
missing data on many series so the the
relationships around income level or
education level or other variables we've
used to make the best estimate we can to
fill the holes so so on a constant
rolling basis we are pulling in new data
series we've got a team of half a dozen
graduate students who do practically
nothing else other than polling data and
as we pull in data in half an hour once
the data in the system I can rerun this
build the base and I can have the
preprocessor will recalculate everything
when we want to move the base year from
2010 2 2015 which will happen in a few
more years we will use the preprocessor
there would be things to clean up
there'll be lots of loose ends but it's
going to say it saves us a huge amount
of time question here and then there so
where you get data on corruption you
done where do we get it to two major
sources one is called the transparency
international it's the international
non-governmental organization which was
based initially in Berlin and they
release what they call measures of
transparency the inverse of corruption
every year and hit the hints of
transparency international and the
second sources is a project of the world
bank called world governance indicators
and world governance indicators
reproduces six different series on
governance performance one of them is
corruption also rule of law
effectiveness voice and participate
but those are the two sources and again
they produce substantially different
numbers and rankings we tend to rely
I'll actually use both of them in our
system well how much data accumulated so
far in say gigabytes or whatever units
and what rate is it accumulating
gigabytes of data and here I'll take you
into into a part of the system that I I
don't even know myself how to answer
that question but inside our data
directory we have a a file called ifs
historical series and right now it's 218
megabytes of data now that's an
Microsoft Access file we are not
state-of-the-art on computing either in
terms of programming I mean we should be
using sequel server or something right
for our data and we've talked about
switching over many times but we have
limited resources and this does the job
for I said it's a legacy stuff but it
does that does the job it's a huge
database in inside there I don't think
you'll find most anywhere around the
world with the possible exception maybe
of the World Bank's world development
indicators database I don't think you'll
find out a bigger one before I go to the
next question I want to piggyback
something on this one we are also trying
to automate our data import processes a
few years ago every time we wanted to
update a series the graduate student
would sit down and there's a table for
the corruption series inside this file
i'm showing you looking at and we would
manually update that series when we went
to an import an automatic import process
so we would we would pull we'd pull up
that data series and we'd bring it in we
are now we have now almost completed
what we call the batch import process so
we can now take a large excel file from
the from the world development
development indicators World Bank they
now they'll produce it for us and and
it's publicly available and
and within the next two or three months
we'll be able to pull in every series
that we want from that file we can also
pull in similarly everything from the
FAO the food and agriculture
organization or from UNESCO or from the
international energy agency what I want
is in going back to that vision I was
showing you before I want a metadata
base that I want a system that can reach
out and grab these data update them
weekly if necessary on automatically
we're not there yet but I don't think
it's going to be that many years so the
two hundred and 218 megabytes is a tiny
file well there's a lot a lot of data in
there yeah but I mean it is a tiny file
okay yeah modern truck that's true you
know we talked about multi petabyte
databases all the time ah what would
happen what would you need in order to
have a larger database which would
improve your results what's missing
actually would go back to better data
rather than more data fundamentally I
think that well actually maybe I'll
retract that answer I think it's both
actually it's better and and more there
are if we go into those tables there are
lots of holes or many of the series the
developing countries of the world many
of them have only been reporting data
for 30 or 40 years maybe even less and
so there are a lot of holes the and the
quality of the data are often weak the
the series that we don't have would
would allow us to move to a different
level of analysis and maybe this is
closer to what you're getting at we're
country based so our data are at the
country level we have begun to extend
this model so that we can take countries
and we can open them up in two states or
provinces or districts or whatever they
call the subject the lower level of
units we have now developed some we've
done prototype work on both India and
China and we have a project with the
western cape provincial
and within South Africa to do that they
also have done it from Mexico but but
that's that's an evolving thrust now you
could you can move down from these are
still political social political units
you could move down from there to a to a
a grid unit you can move down to minutes
on a grid map globally and for
environmental data for instance the
impact of that global warming let's take
a talk about that for a moment we've got
those co2 build-up we've taken we've
rebuilt relationships between co2
build-up and global temperature increase
we basically look to some of the larger
global circulation models for instance
and try to pull out their understanding
of that relationship and we put a
simplified version of that in here and
we've taken that that build up of global
temperature on a global level and
converted it to the implications for
individual countries what does this mean
in terms of precipitation or temperature
for Sweden vs Botswana and we did that
using grid based analysis but we that's
was done offline what I'd love to have
in a model like this isn't is a
combination between the country and
socio-political based now analysis and
the grid based analysis for instance at
Columbia University there's something
called season there it's a it's an
institute that that does a lot of
environmental analysis and does use them
the more grid based system that those
kinds of databases get extremely large
very quickly and if we had that kind of
database it would be monstrous compared
to the one that you've just referred to
and that is by those standards quite
small it would require a different kind
of set of formulations within the model
but one of the things that's going to
happen to these these models these world
problem solving or alternative futures
models over time is going to be that
integration it has not happened yet so
if util model yeah you can think it is
some sort of function which depends upon
or scenario model which depends upon
some scenario have you built any project
or any metod script that goes through
scenarios trying to find a situation
that will that you pre specify that is
it try to do some optimization with this
system or is that something that is left
to the human user okay that would be
what I'm referring to out here our
strategy search tools that is to say we
instead of using what is called an
exploratory scenario approach where we
where we I intervene and ask what are
the consequences of the intervention
using a more normative scenario approach
where we say here's where we want to get
to what are what are some of the paths
and then there might be multiple paths
so that makes it a complex situation but
what are the past to get from here to
there we have done we've experiment a
little bit of that a few years back in
cooperation with a group at rand
corporation in Santa Monica there's a
group there the developed is something
called cars system or robust scenario
planning and and what it requires in in
in in required at that time was to take
this model and run it over and over and
over again obviously to create a map of
the paths and then to try to figure out
what would be a robust path from here to
there we've we found that this model is
was so large already in terms of the
things that are in it that we were
having trouble creating that nap and and
finding a stable path from here to there
it's the next it's an exercise we put on
hold at that time but it's one that is
on my my vision for where this Court of
back the activity should go here
question are there other researchers
building models like this do they use
the same data
do they come to the same conclusions
what what's the I'm going to feel like
yeah what what is the feel like here are
the other people doing the same sort of
thing I'm going to I'm going to stand
here and make a statement that is maybe
a bit of an exaggeration but not a lot
and that is fundamentally no I mean
there are there are two groups out there
that are doing a significant part of
what we're doing one is at this
international institute for applied
systems analysis in Vienna and they have
representations of demographics
education some of the health variable
some of the economic variables and
they've got it they've got
representations and submodels for the
environmental variables but a lot of
that is not fully integrated as it is
with with our system there are artists
porting there's exogenous a connection
between those systems moreover those
systems are not available online or for
download purposes for people to use with
an interface like ours so that you can
actually go in and start playing with
scenarios so they're they're part way
towards us and they've got some really
good models by the way I don't want to
denigrate that any in any way some of
their models are probably better than
ours i'm not sure but but but the they
lack a couple features that we have
there's another group in the netherlands
associated with the ministry of health
and the environment and that group also
has some integrated model components
they don't tend to work fully down at
the country level they work with global
regions and they don't have all the
components that we have in their system
and again it's for the most part not
used outside of the their own operation
on their own institution and then beyond
that there are bits and pieces of mostly
those stovepipe model representations
that I was talking about at the
beginning I think that's it we're out of
questions perhaps okay those of you who
have more questions should come down and
ask them and thank you very much
thank you
you